what's going on guys big sci-fi news CBS
is teaming up with Alex Kurtzman one of
the co writers of the recent Star Trek
films to bring Star Trek back to
television in 2017 what's it gonna be
like who's the cast gonna be we're gonna
talk about that today
and we've got a couple of cool dudes to
talk about it with first he's the critic
at large at the Nerdist her old friend
Kyle Anderson and you know him he's a
comedian and actor hashtag Botanica Mike
Carlson Star Trek is coming back I got
asked are you excited about this yeah I
think it's gonna be a lot of fun I mean
it's been a while since there's you know
been at Star Trek TV show and the last
one was maybe not the best one Star Trek
is the best on TV what Star Trek needs
is an hour long thing to just delve into
politics to get very heavy to get way up
its own ass like that's what we love
about Star Trek yeah to really explore
the worlds and the science this comes at
a perfect time I think I'm kind of
excited about it who do we want to see
there's gonna be new missions new
voyages I want to talk about who we'd
like to see piloting a new craft so who
would you want to see as the captain I
think we should get Viola Davis to do it
but she's a Vulcan okay because if
you've watched how to get away with
murder she's super badass on that show
yes also almost kind of has a Vulcan
haircut already pretty strong choice
Mike Carlson who would you like to see
captain a brand new ship
I want Kathryn Hahn to be the captain
okay and she's a comedic actress she can
be she's in drama she's in crossing
Jordan and like I want to see a captain
who maybe is a little over the job yes
space can play with your head spaces
Mars is no place to raise a kid it's
lonely here in space I was quoting
ground control to Major Tom by the way I
did get that for those of you scoring at
home I did understand that right well I
I like that that wasn't that's Rocket
Man oh wait what am i oh yeah Rocket Man
William Shatner back to the conversation
hi
leave my mistake in the show because you
brought it back nicely okay so how about
a first officer I'm gonna go with
Richard Madden who used to be on Game of
Thrones hmm III think he's a really good
actor he's kind of he can play the young
kind of he just got promoted maybe and
like this is the first time he's been
the commander of a starship uh who would
you pick as a first officer I'm thinking
Giancarlo Esposito he's the guy who like
really like the prime directive he's
very intense about it and then maybe
Catherine Hans character a little but
more laissez-faire about some of that
stuff Wow
yeah he's he's fantastic next give us
another member of your crew chief
medical officer yes I think it would be
fun to do Richard Jenkins I want to go
back to the divorced Kelly way of doing
it he doesn't like anything that happens
but yeah a little bit shaken up not
always together kind of and uh like a
melancholy guy to like really soulful
not like just like a you know cold
doctor I was like yeah for my medical
officer I'm going with Scott Porter he's
sort of like an eager guy he's like a
very like kind of earnest person and
like he's gonna probably like sort of
butt heads like he's gonna sort of be
the guy maybe they pick on a little bit
because he's so like so kind of like
bright-eyed and like wants to do the
right thing interesting choices here you
guys you put some thought into this just
23 skidoo a Star Trek cast Mike let's
start with you this time give us another
member of your crew my security chief is
a robot character played by Justin
roiland
of Rick and Morty Fame he's a very
unassuming robot he's obviously got some
sort of a weird voice but the robots
very powerful like you know it can beat
the crap out of people like it knows
what to do
gotcha so the rope and the robot that
you're envisioning looks somewhat
mild-mannered
yes but it's capable of just opening up
a can a space walk pass whenever need be
space walk pass yes I went a little more
traditional with my security chief I
Dave Bautista but as a Gorn the gland of
course from the episode arena we already
have proven that he can play an alien
yep absolutely and he's not opposed to
wearing a crapload of makeup on his face
so you guys were really bringing the
heat
okay chief engineer I picked another
actor who got killed off of a popular TV
show uh Rick cause net he was on the
first season of the flash yes and he
played Eddie Thawne I thought he was
really great on that and I
if you give him a robotic arm that he
has all the like you know it's like a
Swiss Army knife arm Swiss arm you get
it okay a chief engineer for you Mike
Carlson I'm gonna go he's gonna be an
alien but he's one of my favorite actors
of all time Wallace Sean Princess Bride
he's Rex and Toy Story he's got the
greatest voice in the universe he'll be
some sort of a blue alien and he'll be
very flustered all the time he's an
older gentleman and like things will be
blowing up and he will just be freaking
out and he'll have that amazing voice we
all love let's let's pick our ultimate
crew out of your choices captain
Viola Davis versus Kathryn Hahn well I
mean they're they're completely
different styles I think of captaining I
think both could could work that's tough
that's that's real tough you know what
let's go Kathryn Hahn it's fully
supported it's a great great choice
first officer Richard Madden versus
Giancarlo Esposito so what how do you
envision Giancarlo Esposito he's very
much like the straight man in the
relationship in a way like all you need
to follow the prime directive we need to
not interfere this is she's like trying
to get maybe a short cut and he's the
one he's the uptight one how do you
envision Richard Madden
I think opposite Kathryn Hahn then he
could be the one who is sort of going
way off book he's really hot head he's
trying to you know make a name for
himself and that kind of brings her back
to be like alright I can't be over this
quite yet I have to be the voice of
reason even though I think most of what
we're doing is not great it's a toughy
but I feel like Esposito would be the
better foil I think that's probably true
Karlsson its Haun and Esposito chief
medical officer Richard Jenkins were
Scott Porter well I mean he we want
someone to be sort of the a complete
optimist somebody to be like who can see
all of this all of these worlds through
like fresh eyes where do you come down
on a Richard Jenkins yeah I think a
world-weary
you know soulful sort of he's seen too
much war he doesn't want to do it
anymore you know what I love Richard
Jenkins is an actor so much and you know
Scott Porter I like him but I think I
got to go Jenkins on this one I feel
like he is the extreme version of
Catherine Hans character chief security
officer Justin roiland vs. Dave Bautista
so again I'm just subverting
expectations and going with a guy who's
very unassuming but since he's an
Android
he can do a lot of crazy things and Dave
Bautista you need somebody who's super
intimidating I'm not gonna lie I'm in
the bag for Dave Bautista I love the guy
I'd love to see him in that role that
would rule my world to have Dave
Bautista there BAM Dave Bautista our
chief security officer down to our last
one our chief engineer talk to me about
Wallace Sean I mean put the picture of
him up and tell me that's not a good
idea
Rick cos net I think reconnaissance a
really good actor and I think it'd be an
interesting choice but I actually think
well Sean in blue makeup is a better
choice so I changed my vote entirely
Wallace Sean with a Swiss Army knife arm
boom could not be more perfect yes okay
but now we got to name this show so we
put the cast together what does this
cast do specifically is this sort of a
more of a battleship maybe this is a
heavy artillery type of ship something
that really gets to mix it up yes Star
Trek torpedo Junction Defender they
could be the defender Oh
Star Trek Defender I think it's great I
think it paints a picture yep you're
evocative well guys there you have it
presenting the crew of Star Trek
defender coming maybe never but wouldn't
it be awesome hey what would your ideal
Star Trek starship crew be let us know
in the comments section below the best
answers we are going to send you a
screen junkies t-shirt and tell us what
the name of your show would be as well I
want to thank my awesome crew right here
Kyle Anderson check him out in the
Nerdist Mike Carlson hashtag Botanica
I'm Hal Rudnick thanks for watching hit
me up on Twitter bye bye Renee Zellweger
and Matthew McConaughey - well respected
actors who I'm sure are thrilled that
this footage will